okay hi everyone we are doing a design
review or discussion about category
Theory
and uh it's implementation of Morphin
language
and Jonathan has been doing a bunch of
work on this and
uh this is his notebook
oh my gosh abstract quiver do I really
start here
what um
okay
so
let me just try to understand what
what is the I mean the the principle
here is
what does this roughly mean is this yeah
go ahead Maybe
so I mean the directive directed
multigraph right I mean that's all the
quiver is
um the thing that's significant about
the quiver is that it has it has sort of
essentially representation theoretic
properties that means you can uh that
mean you can you can treat it as the as
the underlying generating set of a
category if you like
is there just just as a syntax question
is there a way of specifying uh I don't
know what the terminology is like in the
version of in the person there it's
you're specifying the more physics but
is there a way of specifying objects
that don't have any morphisms yes so in
the first argument you can give a list
of objects
um okay it's a and I I try to make it as
analogous to graph as possible
sorry what's the difference between a
category and a quiver right so
equivalence is a just a just a
multi-graph right it's just the reason
for the name is that it's a collection
of arrows
a category you can generate you can
consider a category to be generated by a
quiver by you you know you introduce
this binary composition operation you
impose associativity and identity
so in effect graph theoretically you can
think of it as being some generalization
of a transitive closure operation
applied to equivalent
along with introduction of self loops
okay okay so I see so the quiver is just
a bunch of disembodied morphisms
basically right right and together with
go ahead terminologically in the
framework I distinguish between arrows
which are things that equivalent and
Muslims which are the things that exist
in the category
okay
and so why is it the case
that by the way did we invite Charles
could somebody please invite Charles to
this meeting yeah I'll ping him right
now
again he he was he should have been on
the invite list I think he was on the
invite list but
okay so I mean another version of this
would be something like directed Edge I
mean that would be a why is that kind of
not
the I mean that would be sort of seems
like the natural way to represent in our
framework one of these I mean perhaps
that's two objects first morphism second
type thing yeah I mean you can I mean if
you if you give abstract quiver or
abstract category a just a directive
graph right or a collection of directed
edges it will it will work
okay let me just put this somewhere
sorry another point is I mean I assume
in that model it has a way of having
quote-unquote Anonymous arrows I mean
Anonymous instance it makes up a name
for them right right so uh it just I
think by default indexes them it calls
them you know F1 F2 F3 or something
so so hold on so if I put in that
directed Edge into a quiver for example
you'd give it a list of
objects and then a list of directed
edges
so I'll say x y z
and then a list of
directed Edge
X to Y directed Edge
y to z g it may not pick up the uh the
names
correct
okay
okay so this thing there has a way of
visualizing so these things in general
have a
labeled graph
yup
oops what's that
that doesn't seem what is that why did
that go blue and why is it is this a
packlet thing I mean because that I
would have expected it to say resource
function of abstract cover there
that that generally happens with summary
boxes produced by resource functions
okay anybody understand that Nick do you
understand that
so yeah that's what happens
a box box head contains like just a
symbol
without the context of functional
Repository
maybe it's hidden
okay so I don't understand that doesn't
seem like the right thing so this is
probably Ian do you know anything about
this anybody else know anything about
this
no
okay so that that seems like a function
repository is to to be tracked down
well so I mean there's there's a
trade-off right you you can have the
full context in the summary Box Thing uh
but then it appears everywhere wherever
you have that summary box and it looks
really ugly
um you mean the resource function thing
yes okay somebody needs to look at this
Kristen you need to take this to
somebody who understands the resource
system yes and figure out what we want
to do about this
okay so I mean and there may be enough
functions here that it may be that it
wants to end up as a packlet of some
kind I'm not sure but but let's just
understand what you've got here to begin
with so this is this a formal is this a
formal symbol this F1 this is a
generated F1 yeah exactly that's that's
why they've got the dots there therefore
I mean I think that there's a piece of
beautification that should happen here
in terms of these actual diagrams I'm
not quite sure why it's such heavy font
and all that kind of thing but this is a
minor issue but I think we should
we should have its fonts done and
perhaps I don't know whether these
things always want to be black and white
I mean all of these design choice I
agree they're not optimized but they
were designed to make them look like you
know commutative diagrams that you'd see
in a paper or something sure which they
succeed in doing so I mean I think it's
just a question of picking the fonts and
so on
um
and uh
yeah so those are absolute sized of some
kind
okay but let's just understand so we've
got this notion of these Quivers which
are collections of arrows between
objects now and and crucially
you know the the thing that makes this
again a sort of an algebraic or at least
a representation theoretic object or
presentation theoretic object is that
you can Define uh relations right you
can Define relations between objects and
you can Define relations between uh
between arrows
explain
so I mean I think if you scroll down
you'll see some some examples in the I
mean in the documentation you'll see
some examples I think in the second
example I showed some so
um okay that's the simple labeled graph
uh if you go down a bit further
[Music]
um
yeah okay there we go there's an example
of an equivalence opposed between
objects right so if you give the full
labeled graph it treats Z and W as being
distinct but if you ask for the reduced
labeled graph it will collapse them to
one vertex
okay
okay so wait a minute so first of all
we've got this collection of morphisms
between these objects and
uh wait a minute why
arrows right
so trap there is no transitive closure
it's just what you specify as what you
get here right
um
and there is no guarantee I mean
okay fine all right so now unlabeled
graph fine okay reduced labeled graph
okay so this is reduced with w and z
treated as equivalent
so those nodes have been collapsed into
into one node right right and so you can
Define relations between objects and you
can Define relations between arrows as I
mean as you see down in the next um
cells there we go so what kinds of oh I
see so the relations between objects and
between arrows are different different
arguments and and do they um is equal
the only thing that they can take or
could you say something
and really know what you would say and
it said to me oh F compose G is equal to
you know R composed Q or something like
that right I mean so obviously you can't
do that in equivalent but you can do
that in a category right so you could
give arbitrary compositions of of arrows
in a you know you could make relations
between arbitrary compositions of arrows
okay one design relations are always
represented as you know compositions of
of things on either side and they're
equal or are there other kinds of things
you could say no I mean so so equality
is the only relevant predicate yeah
maybe you should also support two-way
rule as a Syntax for that does that make
sense it does okay fine
um
good okay
okay as you can see internally the
quiver is just an association of objects
arrows object equivalences Arrow
equivalences
yeah that's nice
okay
um yeah
last time we saw an example where you
could have an arrow equivalence that you
could potentially
um deduce object equivalences from
um right does it do that now or uh so
not in the version that's deployed
but in the in the in the version on the
GitHub that's
um still the development Branch it yeah
that that is modified so you could so if
you introduce an arrow okay first of all
if you introduce an arrow equivalence
that's inconsistent it will tell you it
will complain and if you introduce one
that requires an object equivalence it
will impose that equivalence implicitly
okay
okay
um all right so let's maybe maybe should
we go on to looking at categories now
right
okay
so go ahead if you again if you maybe
you take that abstract category object
and look at this Association form it may
make it a bit clearer what's going on
um oh yeah you can just do that yeah
oops there's no
uh that's just an auto complete missing
no no there's no way yeah I can't know
that
okay it has its quiver
yeah so every category is generated by
so you can think of the the quiver the
arrows and the quiver is essentially
providing like algebraic generators for
the category if you like and you've got
the composition symbol uh you've got a
symbol that represents identity
morphisms and then you've got lists of
objects amorphism equivalences
this is nice so now a question if we put
this into you know axiomatic Theory like
like this format here it'd be nice to
have that compatible with axiomatic
Theory right
which it almost is here
um
okay fine I understand so now what do we
do with this
so this is
so this is now
the category version of this which has
in addition the you know the the closure
morphism so to speak indicated here
right exactly so if you did a more
complicated example
um then you could also look you can look
at um one of the the properties of
category include things like
associativity equations and identity
equations you can see which equalities
are effectively imposed by the axioms of
category Theory
I see so if I if I do that you have an
example here I mean if you just add one
more Arrow to that category you
generated above in in the notebook then
so if you make an arrow H from Z to W or
something you you can see an example of
that
okay so then if you say category uh say
um associativity equations
out of curiosity roughly how many of
these sort of sub values do these have
they have like a hundred of them or are
they there are loads I mean if if you
ask for properties if you say category
properties
a little bit off
my God
my God
so is this is this most functionality is
in the uh the sub values
well yeah I mean each one of these is
intended to be a very general function
right so obviously abstract category has
a lot there are lots of things you might
want to do with categories so it has a
lot of properties right right
um
but yeah as you can see you can com you
can determine
you know when categories represent
commutative diagrams you can compute
monomorphisms epimorphisms retractions
sections
um endomorphisms automorphisms you can
get zero objects
um you can compute constant and
co-constant morphisms there's it like
anything you might reasonably the the
plan was always any computation you
might reasonably want to do with a
category should be supported by abstract
category
okay that's cool I mean but now okay
groupoid Q I want to optimize like the
the currently are handling for group
words is not very good I need to
optimize that a bit
foreign
would be something much more
uh
yeah you you can try you can try and
build one right so if you if you take
um
I mean the minimal case would be
something like if you had f x it goes
from X to what goes from y to X and then
you impose relations that say you know G
compose F and F compose G are equal to
the identities that would give you a
minimal example of a groupoid
okay but but so so let's just try to
understand some of these
okay so what we've got here I mean again
these are all very abstract category
type stuff and I think what you would
started talking about is what happens
when you go to more concrete categories
where these F's and G's are actually
um
uh you know are actually wolfen language
functions for example right exactly and
in a sense the the idea is to use all
the abstract stuff that we've developed
so far to be a kind of skeleton for the
concrete category framework which is
kind of where it gets potentially more
interesting because
no no I'm just a very practical point if
somebody happens to just be able to Ping
Jeremy and see if he could just spend
two minutes here and see if he can give
us some specifications to make these you
know for fonts and things that would
make these look more beautiful yes I'll
pick him I mean if he isn't available
it's a bit but but um I just think this
is so close to being really beautiful
but it isn't quite beautiful
um sorry what were you going to say so
the the I think I get it these are this
is
I mean this is essentially sort of a
labeled graph Theory with transitive
closures in it and then you're asking
for many properties of these graphs
which are you know
you know just like like every one of
these I mean we could imagine a world in
which these were all separate functions
just like we can check for a graph you
know is this a complete graph and so on
you can check all kinds of things for
this right right I I think I think the
outcome of the last meeting we had about
this was that we shouldn't do that in
this case no okay finally because there
are a bajillion of them right right I
don't I don't think we want to flood the
function repository with 300 category
Theory functions
right it does seem to me though this
probably is more of a pack like than a
function repository I think that that's
a different issue I mean and right now I
mean again in the GitHub version it
essentially is a it is treated as a
packlet
um
it's just exposed through the functional
Repository
yeah which is fine okay all right
so this is this is fine so as a this is
a totally random question but but the
the composition I'm not sure what symbol
you're using the circle dot thing
um is there a reason why you don't uh
use like a varark's form of it
given that's associative
well it's because I want to be able to
have the associativity equations
as part of the I mean as as an actual
property
um
okay I I'm not totally sure I I don't
know enough about when this will be used
to understand when that would be useful
but but sure sure
well I mean so there are situations in
which you actually want to be able to
track
which identities are imposed by the
associativity axioms versus which
identities are imposed by the user
um you know actually defining their own
equivalences
um and effectively if we had a varog's
form of you know if we had a an operator
that opposed imposed associativity you
know
um
just by its structure we'd we'd lose the
information about that's currently
encoded in the associativity equations
which is quite useful
is there any relevance to this
application operator it's a left to
right I don't know this is probably
irrelevant I can't even remember how to
use it it's left to right
function composition
isn't it the same as that star
no it's not it's at Star reversed right
we're just slash star
okay
it's not that either it's we introduced
this this was the original thing that
you know the combinator people
were this is what originally people
thought was going to be the way to do
function composition back 100 years ago
is it just a pure symbolic thing or does
it actually evaluate
I I'm trying to remember that this
doesn't look like it evaluates
has no built-in meaning okay fine okay
okay
fine
yeah okay so but I just I'm but Jonathan
you're aware of this but it isn't
relevant it's that basically the picture
I I think so I mean you there is the
question I mean you brought up the a
slightly independent thing about whether
you want to have notation for reverse
function composition right
um which is interesting and and which
does get used in in category Theory
literature very often it's denoted with
sort of semicolons and things
so rather than saying decompose F you'd
say F semicolon G
um that's something but there already is
I mean in case you don't know I mean
there already is there's composition and
there's right composition which is the
two I'm aware and that gets and in the
concrete category framework where these
operators really are function
composition in the Well from language
sense we use those
okay well let's take a look at this so
okay so fine so we've got
an abstract functor
my God how many problems does this
creature have
again functor is a pretty fundamental
um so a lot
oh my gosh hey Jeremy I'm just yeah
we're talking about category Theory and
it's full of diagrams like this
okay okay our mission is to make these
look less ugly
um
comments
well how labels versus the graph in the
background are
how important are these labels because
they seem really bold and large
well they're the main event really okay
to say I mean the they could lighten the
graph then I mean you could go gray it's
everything's black and so if you had
some something lighter
yeah but I think it would help this
these fonts I mean Jonathan can you say
what the font is that you're using and
things uh not offhand hang on I can
double check
it might be worth just go if you just go
to you know Google images and look up
category Theory or something just to
show some examples of how these are
usually shown
let's take a look here
um I mean maybe stuff like like
maybe making the the letters the objects
less bold or something I'm not sure this
could be smaller too they just seem
oversized
this is just looking something help but
this look at this for these objects
there oh you are doing that as well well
usually it looks like they have it's
usually you know it's uppercase italic
and serifft and not bold
yeah so okay I just checked so right now
we're just using vertex label style and
Edge label style directive bold 20.
that's the only font information okay so
I mean this looks like a typical
category Theory
thing yeah and that's more or less what
I was trying to model
so maybe we should just pick a a
non-bold and seraphy font
yes I mean like also they're using small
circle
for composition and I'm not sure why we
aren't using that because that would
seem like the natural thing to use
unless that means something different
I tried it I didn't like the way it like
the operator seemed too small but
there's a major speaking Yeah but okay
so that that's a that's the that might
be a question of um it's got the other
category Theory John some people admit
that the operator all together they just
write you know FG or something for
composition yeah no that that's that's
unacceptable okay but I mean this seems
to be a typical not very beautiful
diagram but Jeremy what do you think in
terms of um I mean I I agree that having
a slightly different color for the
you know characters and the arrows might
help this look better can we look at
Jonathan's again
yeah
and the labels are crashing some of
these are okay but some of them are
crashing into the line so space around
the label so they don't touch lines
that's a question of putting putting
some I mean that that's a question for
the graph framework
which I think you need to invent a way
to scare you know you can't if you have
a complex graph and you try to label
everything and the big labels it's just
it's impossible
so but on the other hand what you could
do is to
to use you know tooltip you can use a
legend so you don't have them right
there but you have sort of a reference
to them where they apply
um yeah but I mean remember well we'll
see in the case of concrete categories
what this is being used for but I
suspect
okay there's a question of scaling the
labels for example here
it could be done with scaled fonts
I know it feels like even this would
look better if there was slight grayness
and possibly even some them in color I
mean I don't know whether that you know
Jonathan is there any kind of I mean
look for example that person
you know that looks rather nice having
different colors for for the um uh it it
does my my concern is just that there's
no standards
um version of that right that um the the
only notation that's even vaguely
standardized is precisely the kind of
pure black
um yes but that's mostly because people
don't print books usually in colors
other than black I mean I think that
were they to be printed in some other
color people just think they look
stylish
because it isn't black
uh well I mean if you
you and or Jeremy want to invent a color
scheme for category Theory I'm not going
to complain I think we should I think we
should I think we should invent what
what I mean relative to the physics
project for example where we I mean
because realistically things like
branchial pink has been very successful
so my question is is there only one kind
of Arrow here is that kind of an essence
of category theories there's there's
morphism you know purple or something
not purple we've already used that but
it is you know morphism gray or
something like this I mean there's just
the arrows are all the same kind of
thing right well are you going to
distinguish between arrows and morphisms
or ones that are compositional versus
ones that aren't I mean how fine of a
distinction should there be kind of
chromatically or or do we want to
distinguish between identity morphisms
and others yeah right even imagine a
situation where like you know the uh the
retractions or the isomorphisms or the
monomorphisms get highlighted in a
different color as James said there's
like there's there are many different
levels of granularity you can imagine I
think that seems nice I mean if look
look here's the thing these diagrams are
pretty hard to understand in general one
of the things that we've been very
successful with in the physics project
is using color as a way to make diagrams
easier to understand so why not use that
again well because the only issue is if
if there's you know epimorphism green
and monomorphism it's going to look like
a bowl of cereal you know if you're not
careful right
um
uh right no I mean that that's it's not
going to work to have many colors but
the question is is there you know maybe
there's one basic color
I don't know I don't know I I don't know
this field well enough to know this
I mean
in in in this picture
which things these things that map
things to themselves what what are those
those are the identity morphisms okay
where's there an isomorphism here what
what's the what's the defining feature
of an isomorphism in these pictures so
in isomorphism is one where I mean again
you you could you can build one if you
want so an isomorphism is one which is
isomorphism which is both a left and
right invert or both left and right
invertible
um
explain so maybe it's again I think it's
I think I genuinely think it's easier to
explain if we do an example so if you if
you build a category that uh just has um
just goes it has two morphisms one
um f from X to Y and one from one G from
y to X let's say
okay
yeah yeah the morphisms just go both
ways right right but that's not
crucially that's not yet an isomorphism
right so if you look at the reduced
labeled graph of that
um that's a very bizarre message
bug of some kind
reduced
labeled graph labeled graph
okay so you can see there's now a g
compose F and an F compose G and a
priori then G compose f is not equal to
Identity on X and F compose G is not
equal to Identity On y
okay so so neither F nor G is an inverse
of the other yet right okay uh but then
you could impose a pair of
um relations that says G compose f
equals x i density and F compose g
equals y identity which would make f and
g equal to okay how do I how do I say
that so um first you want to put an
empty list because you're not import
you're not imposing any uh equivalences
between objects then you want to put a
list
in the first instance you could just say
Circle dot g comma f equals equals over
tilde of capital X
F comma what uh let's do G comma F let's
do the X tilde one equals equals
um over tilde
of x
okay and then what uh so then
let me let's just check that works for a
second
um and so if you if you do the reduce
labeled graph of that
uh you should see now
yeah so now that's collapsed to that so
if you ask for
um
say monomorph sorry if you asked for
retractions or and sections of that
you can see that g is now a retraction
and F will correspondingly be a section
right so that's your attraction that
means that g is acting as a left inverse
and F is acting as a right inverse
okay and so if you said like left
inverses as a property you can see you
can see that explicitly
so yeah g is now the left inverse of f
right okay
um and so now if you if they if they if
the morphism is both a left and right
inverse then it's an isomorphism
okay
okay
yeah go ahead and and so for instance
okay there's actually an automatic way
that you can compute that so in in cases
where you've got um you know morphisms
that go in both directions but you
haven't yet imposed all the relevant
equivalences you can request groupoid
equations
of this yeah and it will return the
minimal set of equations between
morphisms necessary to turn that
category into a groupoid in other words
to make every isomorphous every morphism
and isomorphism cool okay
so that will tell you yeah right yeah
it's like how you can also request like
commutativity equations and it will give
you the minimal set of equations between
morphisms necessary to make a diagram
commutative
which in this case happens to be the
same thing
um but in more General cases it's not
so if I were to take like this crazy
puppy here yes
uh let's see I can't pick up can I pick
up this is this thing
something I can pick up and do things
with or is that just a graph oh that's
just the graph output no that's just the
graph output I mean of course you can
put a directed graph back into abstract
category or abstract quiver and it will
generate it will generate the free
category or the free quiver from that
graph but
okay and and hopefully you're going to
include the the um labeled edges so that
it will so that it directly picks up the
the names yeah
okay so if I take this and I take
that rather slightly more complicated
thing and then I say something like
commutativity equations here exactly and
by the way that could auto complete
okay cool and so then if you impose so
then if you imposed those commutativity
equations as relations between morphisms
then commutative diagram Q would return
true
yep okay so then let's just do that just
for fun so how do I add that to the
category how do I add those conditions
to the category wait uh I think you've
picked up the wrong category there
oh well that wouldn't help but um but
yeah so in the same way as before if if
after the um no I understand that but
I'm asking from from externally if I've
just got the category as a box is there
a wait yes so you could you can call
abstract category of an abstract
category and then impose new objects on
it okay so then here you're saying these
are relations between morphisms so I
just took them right in here uh yeah you
want to have an empty list first again
objects for the objects yeah
okay and now you can see commutative
diagram as true in the summary box
where whereas it would have been false
before
okay so if I now take that thing and I
say uh
full labeled graph
yeah then you'll still because the
because in the full graph you don't
impose equivalences right that's what
the full means
um whereas if you said reduce label
graph you'd see those directed edges
collapsed back to
okay why is this commutative diagram
well effectively because there are no
multi-edges right
so what it means is a graph
theoretically what it means for a
diagram to be commutative I mean what
you're saying when you say a diagram
commutes right is you're saying that
between any any directed path between a
pair of objects it yields the same
result
yes so in the in the uh in the reduced
labeled graph picture what that's saying
I mean essentially that just reduces to
a purely graph theoretic calculation of
you know uh do there exist multi edges
so wait a minute if I say full labeled
graph yeah then the fact that H compose
G compose F and H compose sorry H equals
G1 compose F and H compose G2 compose f
are both edges from X to w
that is an indicator that this diagram
this is not yet commutative if you don't
impose any equivalences
what would it mean to I I thought
commutative meant it went backwards what
am I I'm confused here no no that's no
that's not so it
if you read a um if you read a paper on
you know homological algebra or
something and it says this diagram
commutes what it means is that
um if you you know if you start at the
top left and you end at the bottom right
uh all
um you know all directed paths between
those two objects yield the same result
is that like confluence
it's
um
not really
why not
because all all paths from you're saying
all paths from from anything to anything
there are always paths I'm confused I
think it's not a statement about the
structure of the graph it's a statement
about about if you follow the arrows
it's an algebraic statement yeah yeah it
says it has the same effect
because these are mappings right these
are functions exactly but I could draw a
category where I've got well you know I
could have a thing of you know one more
one one one Edge is sort of like you
know the plus two operation and other
Edge is the times two operation that
doesn't commute I can still draw that
diagram
right
so okay so I think this is going to be
clearer when we actually go to concrete
categories which hopefully we're about
to do
um
I have a question quick one it's like I
usually underneath you just simplify
with assumptions in order to reduce all
of those equalities like for all the
paths from every pair of objects you
like as you move them and you simplify
an assumptions something like that
how do the reduction
uh you could think of I mean yeah it's
effectively like a simplified with
assumptions there's there's a very very
minimal
um theorem prover that's effectively the
core of this that that does those you
know it does the the finite model
they're improving case that you yeah is
effectively like a simplified with
assumptions how does it I mean does is
it algorithmically sophisticated at all
or does it need to be
uh for the well for the handling of
universal properties it needs to be
somewhat algorithmically sophisticated
but I mean in in practical uses of this
you know the the category diagrams
people drawing books are tiny like these
but is there a practical use where you
have a category diagram with a million
you know a million objects in it and
things sure
okay does anybody use those in in
current I mean other than the kinds of
things people don't draw the pictures
right but but most categories are
infinite
yes but I know but I mean a million is
large but I've never seen one with even
a hundred Jonathan what's the largest
category you've ever seen like in the
literature that's actually drawn out
maybe in terms of amorphism well it's
important to note that when people draw
diagrams they're usually not drawing the
entire structure of a category right
they're they're drawing an indexed
family of objects and morphisms usually
um
but yeah I mean the largest commutative
diagram I've ever seen was in a paper by
Lurie that like spanned like two pages
or something
um and that was viewed as kind of
obscene
um what was it about and what kind of a
thing was it
I was it was some coherence condition
for a higher top loss Construction
um okay
but so so you can think of that as
defining in some sense these are like
equations but this is a kind of a
notation
how should we think about this I mean
this is because I mean there's a there's
a nice phrase in McLean's book where he
describes commutative diagrams as like
the you know commutative diagrams are to
categories what equations are to algebra
okay
but so I mean it's it's it's it's kind
of a very compact notation to give a
huge num potentially a large number of
equations yes
yeah exactly I mean as you can probably
tell it you don't have to grow these
things very large before the the output
of commutativity equations gets very big
well so if I wait a minute what do we do
here we did we have
community of the equations there okay
um
do you do do you find things like cycle
bases and things to minimize the number
of equations you have to list
uh no but that's an interesting
optimization so that
um
no I mean the the the the the way that
it's effectively done right now is we
find a set of equations and then we do
um we do algebraic simplification on
that
um but then maybe yeah it'd be
interesting what how I mean using
how are you doing the actual
simplification here like I said at the
core there's like a mini equational
theorem prover
okay that does the simplification
amongst other things so cycle bases is
is a way to well enumerate the basis for
all the cycles
yeah right so I mean but if we thought
about this in terms of algebraic
equations
what would be
I'm just trying to get a sense of
it's saying W is equal to this yeah I
see I mean okay fine so we could write
out this whole diagram as a bunch of
equations that's you know h of Z is
equal to W and so on
uh
uh well it's yes I suppose
I mean that's effectively what your what
is going to happen when you make these
um well and and so so right now because
you know we're dealing with the finite
case the theorem proving that goes on
here is quite simple but if you if you
pull up a version involving Universal
properties like you know pullbacks or
push-outs or something then you see a
slightly more interesting slightly more
sophisticated version and maybe if I
should
sorry what should we look at here look
at pullbacks or something oh I don't
know
so uh if you look at the universal
property
a little bit further down
okay we've got another one we've got
another type of line here I was gonna I
was gonna say is Jeremy's involvement
done now and now we've got another kind
of line but again this is like this is
the standard notation for how Universal
Property gets denoted
is to use dashed lines
okay
well anyway so whereas before we just
had diagrams that represented purely
algebraic equations this is now a
diagram representing a universally
Quantified
um formula why is there a uniqueness
thing there
that means they exists unique that or is
that a point of pullbacks those unique
ones
okay but I don't understand we need to
review pullbacks probably yeah I don't
understand any of this sorry wait well I
I think I dropped in the call for a
second what happened we were discussing
pullbacks from the fact that I don't
understand what they are okay uh maybe
it's easier to start with products then
because products like baby pullbacks
okay but but I I just let's let Jeremy
go uh if I mean
do you have any immediate comments about
this the visual stuff that that um not
yet but I can work with you know whoever
um I'm not sure who I'd work with but
I'm happy to jump in well by the way
just before if Jeremy if you're about to
go I just sent you or I I sent Steven
you a screenshot of like I just tried
changing the fonts and stuff a bit
oh okay
let me just bring that up up help
where did the stock come up
uh I don't see it Christopher I said I
just sent it to to SW Wolfman okay
yeah well that looks very much more like
the textbooks I'm not sure it looks
I think we need some something stylish
somewhere in between these
Jonathan what do you think I mean that
looks very textbooky it does I mean at
the very least I think we should support
that as an option
um but I think what we want is something
in between that is stylishly
you know and and I think here it becomes
clear that this thing is really pretty
oversized and maybe the um
uh maybe Cirque or something is is
better
the circle composition that won't work
because I had to install the latex font
oh I see
I I yeah I didn't know what what font I
mean I assume we have a latex looking
font already somewhere because we use it
for the latex stuff but I didn't know
what it was called
right
okay one concern I have is when you
actually have the full labeled
version which we can see with this
pullback example when those are labeled
those labels become obfuscated I mean
that's a that's a general design
challenge that's something more
photographs and that would be something
where we want those to be call outs with
arrows to the arrows more or less
including additional arrows that aren't
you know categorically meaningful would
be I don't know
because I don't think you can draw an
actual Arrow I think at best you can
have a tool tip or something
yeah I think tooltips is not a terrible
idea like I mean that's that's what we
do with the um with proof graphs right
is like when they reach a certain size
we no longer yeah print things on the
graph itself we you know relegate them
to tooltips
okay anyway so minus things to be done
here we need the color of morphism so to
speak or the color of arrows I think we
should pick some color that is something
you know I I would argue there should be
consonants with the multi-way color
scheme
yeah well which what should it agree
with there should it agree with the the
edges in the multi-way graph because
when you I mean in the in the concrete
case right then these edges are the
edges of a quiver are precisely
Evolution edges in a multi-way system
fine so that's probably then we got our
color
and then I mean but those are but those
are arrows of the quiver what happens
when we actually introduce
compositionality which will have a
different color or not right we haven't
until the CT framework as far as I know
we haven't looked at multi we haven't
looked at the compositional structure of
multi-way systems in that kind of way
right so so perhaps the right thing is
we have a slightly different color that
can be you know a cheerful color of some
kind for
um
uh for the for the actual uh you know
um you know transitively closed whatever
associ you know uh remorse from
morphisms yeah but I I think it's nice I
think as a as a first order thing I
think it'd be kind of nice to see yeah
the the UN like the underlying skeleton
the arrows from the underlying quiver in
a kind of multi-way color and then and
then all all the extraneous all the
additional arrows yeah with as you say
some some Jolly but different color
fine got a new basis for colors here any
way to pick a color
what's the color of I mean you know what
will be any any kind of like trees we
made green okay for
obvious reasons
um
anything other than
yellow math books and things no okay
uh all right well separate problem all
right we should let Jeremy go because
because we're going to go on and talk
about
um look I really wanted to get to this
concrete categories business because I
it looks like a lot of lovely things
with these abstract categories
um is there stuff I I do think it's
worth seeing just
um
because because it's quite different to
the other stuff we've talked about I
think it's worth seeing an example of
Universal Property an example of these
what these monoidal categories can do
okay because they're in some ways the
two do you want to share do you need to
share or can I see uh it's up to you if
you think I mean where is
well so again if we if we start by
looking at abstract products um maybe
that's easier than looking at abstract
callback straight up
so here's a minimal example of a
universal property
um so what you do is you take so that if
you like
one way you could think about abstract
okay the way I like to think about
categorical products is that they're
like General vast generalizations of the
concept of set intersections
okay so if you imagine A and B here are
sets if you imagine all the objects are
sets and if you imagine all the arrows
are essentially inclusion relations
between sets
then how would you then if you think
abstractly how you would Define the
notion of set intersection
the intersection of sets A and B is the
set such that a intersection B is a
subset of a it's a subset of B and
crucially it satisfies a universal
property in the sense that any other set
that's a subset of a and a subset of B
must be a subset of a intersection B yep
and that's precisely what this Universal
property describes so if you scroll down
and show the Universal Property
so here that's exactly what we're seeing
right we're seeing we've got this a
product B we've got these projection
morphisms Pi one Pi 2 into a into a and
b and then we're saying for any y such
that and for any F1 and F2 such that y
inject into a and injects into B there
exists a unique F from y to a a product
B
okay
and so then internally if we scroll down
a bit more
uh that uh more still there we go
Universal product equations down there
internally that just gets translated
into some first order logic that we can
then do Theory improving over
so then this product is just like a
disembodied thing that you can then
embed into some arbitrary category and I
have some examples of that later on in
the documentation
um
so products are is a like a sort of vast
generalization of um of set into
sections co-products which are the Dual
are like the generalization of disjoint
unions
um and then yeah I think the last
example in this in the in the basic
example section
shows uh yeah here we're embedding here
you it's showing how you take a product
and you embed it into some pre-existing
category and and in that when you do
that suddenly it takes this abstract
universally Quantified Universal
Property and it actually instantiates it
on the objects amorphisms of the
category you embedded it in
okay
you know I I really need to see some
applications of this
I mean this is lovely
and and by the way I mean this is this
is to me
this is super helpful to see these
things in this somewhat concrete
computable form as opposed to just
seeing pictures and books
right
um and seems like anybody who's teaching
a category 3 course should be using this
type thing
yeah so products co-pro products
pullbacks push-outs equalizers
co-equalizers limits co-limits these are
all examples of the constructions with
you know involving these Universal
properties in fact so if ordinary
diagrams are like uh equations in
Algebra then these Universal properties
are like you know universally Quantified
logic expressions okay universally and
existentially crucially I mean there's
the both quantifiers exist
okay let's talk about concrete
categories if we could and I think
you've got open questions here which um
oh my gosh connection is the pure math
packlet now Ian might be able to speak
to some of that right
yeah
we met
um the separation axioms for topological
spaces may be able to be characterized
in terms of universal properties but
it's something we'd actually have to use
some creativity to think of
how to encode all the different
properties strictly in terms of
uh Universal properties but I mean and
our representation of pure math
coming to an example can we can we pick
up an example here is there some some
random example where I can see relations
between certain
I don't know properties of topological
spaces or something
yeah can you like do needs of pure math
fact
and then do entity topology concept
comma is T1
there's no autocomplete
topology concept
okay
and then is T1 T1 like this and then get
the property summary grid
foreign
this is like the standard definition of
a T1 topological space
you say every Singleton set is closed
okay you could rephrase this in terms of
what kinds of morphisms exist between
appropriately chosen objects and so the
task would then be to take every concept
that we have at least for separation
axioms and come up with what those uh
this is a great project for somebody
who's like doing classes in this stuff
right now I don't know why am I thinking
of Mano somehow Jonathan Jonathan put a
link in chat of some of some examples of
this
but it's by no means exhaustive
yeah so essentially there's there's a
universal if you consider the category
of topological spaces and continuous
deformations between topological spaces
there's a way you can represent things
like these uh separation axioms purely
in terms of um Universal properties on
these diagrams
um and so then one possibility is that
we might be able to also so some of the
kinds of deductions that right now are
kind of more or less baked into the pure
math in a more or less hard-coded into
the pure math packlet we may be able to
automate more of them at least that
might that that would be the sort of
optimistic hope if we were to encode
more of the assumptions in this category
theoretic way
well so essentially it's a higher level
version of theorem proving where you can
make statements about things which are
stated in terms of morphisms and so on
using essentially you know some kind of
diagram you know Arrow chasing diagramy
type thing is that the idea yeah exactly
so you'd be able to I mean the concept
would be
that just like at the level of sort of
find equational proof you're dealing
with theorem proving that the level of
you know f
you know
you know a dot b dot C equals c dot b
dot a or something
um here you'd be able to make you'd be
able to state things in terms of
what what kinds of statements would you
be able to deal with you'd be able to
say this I don't know what will be an
example of the kind of thing you would
be able to establish like that well if
you could construct these
um you know if you had a way of
representing these concrete categories
of things like topological spaces
then in principle you could prove you
know any statement in topology
but so
I understand I mean you know is there a
sense in which there is sort of an
axiomatic basis for topology represented
in category Theory language
that then has some laws of inference
that are based on sort of diagram
chasing or whatever yeah exactly except
it's yeah it's not an axiomatic oh it's
not
um just in terms of the nomenclature
it's not referred to as an axiomatic
basis but it's but yeah what is it
what's it called
well I think this I think ultimately
this goes back to the thing you were
commenting about Saunders McLean and you
know category Theory being a sort of
non-axiomatic thing but yeah but so
people would just say you know
a categorical or category theoretic
formulation of some mathematical field
but so but what's it what's the
foundation of that I mean so you do you
write down like for topology do we
expect that there's sort of you know 10
lines of stuff you write down to Define
that or do we think it's you know what
is that
yeah
go ahead well so so uh the categorical
description of the the description of
top the specification of top is I think
you can write down in sort of four I've
seen it written down in four or five
rules so kind of comparable to the you
know comparable to the size of the
standard axioms or Point set topology I
think we have it in the pure math
packlet okay
of category
what did I do here
of category the string category
um I don't need to say what what the
isn't it
isn't it topology concept oh um
oh no
that should have worked
did it not load up the entity store
correctly
oh that this might be hidden behind a
flag for unreleased functionality so the
point is like we Define categories the
same way we Define topological spaces
and I'd really like to see this but how
can we get this what's that can I share
my screen yep
that's Stephen I mean it's
you can see quite easily how you could
Define it right
so
there's a very obvious category
theoretic
um
you know formulation of what it means to
be a continuous function right you can
very easily State you know pre-image of
any open set is open but if you if you
have a pre-existing category of open
sets
right that's just a statement about
that's a that's a pure function
composition statement and then if you
make this statement that uh any
continuous function is amorphism in top
then that's sufficient to Define top
okay so wait a minute so what are we
seeing here so we're seeing here
okay so I mean clearly the question for
Jonathan and so on is could we just take
things like this and make non-trivial
deductions
in topology for example
yeah I mean that's yeah that's why we
had this meeting it's uh I mean that's
why um Ian Jack and I had this meeting
to
okay okay
as soon as you check whether that was a
useful thing to do
but so is that do you see that as being
part of your concrete category effort or
this is I mean because it seems like
this is just filling in what f and g
might actually be well I I think I I
kind of view it as being a slightly
orthogonal Direction
um that
in a sense actually what this is more
like is it's this is more like having a
category repository right
where because the concrete category
framework is essentially taking you you
take some specification of a multi-way
or multi-computation and you build a
category out of it now of course you
could do that with topology or whatever
but somehow that doesn't seem like the
right thing to do what I would argue is
potentially more fruitful is to have a
cat is to have a repository of common
categories like set or top or yeah or
whatever have them be represented purely
symbolically and then do automated
reasoning over those
that sounds interesting I mean it sounds
like doing like they're improving but at
a much higher level
yes I mean so in a sense the the so the
framework right now is a theorem proverb
but also a theorem discoverer
so it does I mean
you can both enumerate things that are
true and you can prove that they're true
but the enumeration of things that are
true is a question of certain properties
of I mean you're you're turning making
algebraic certain things that are based
on tracing paths in those graphs is that
true well in the trivial cases yes
um you could you can do that graph
theoretically but for things like for
anything non-trivial like Universe
anything involving Universal Properties
or anything involving functors you can't
do that
I see but so so you believe that there's
a way of enumerating true theorems
I'm not quite yet clear how to do that I
mean in the case of uh
you know in the case of of
um equational kinds of formulations of
things we understand how to just uh you
know use substitution or something to
derive new theorems from old ones what
what's them what's the analogous
mechanism here
well so as you say in the in the pure
category case uh it is essentially just
a you know you can just do it through
some graph theoretic means okay
um in the more sophisticated cases you
have to result you have to fall back to
standard equational theorem proving
methods
on constructs which are like the
constructs that Ian is showing us here
is that right right you're doing
equational theorem proving on uh
morphisms and compositions of morphisms
and there's multiple levels of theorem
proving you might want like proving the
actual theorems of topology from the the
axioms of set theory
and then there's things like proving
relationships between different kinds of
topological properties that might be
able to be done in terms of like diagram
chasing Universal properties so so in
this diagram here were you able to
already establish results from this what
is this diagram this is a this is what
depends on what is that right
no so this is
topological properties so if two spaces
are homeomorphic then they will uh the
the property depends on equivalence
classes like so whether or not
something's a surface depends only on uh
the topology of it not the particular
uh yeah what is this diagram showing
this is showing the dependence if it's
you know is regular
for example yeah like they're direct
implications but the point is that
there's more relations here than just
direct implications
um this is this is like a
like a sub graph okay so what would
something like is regular what would
that turn into in the category Theory
framework
foreign
you have to say oh well I'll I'll give
you a particular object and then give
you relations that exist on the
morphisms between that object and your
space yeah like I said the universal
properties the whole power of these
things to get to the more complicated
kinds of properties each each of these
can be represented or at least the
majority of them as far as I'm aware can
be represented as universal properties
and as Ian said that's kind of why I
sent through that um
that link
okay
but so so so the point is that one is
doing theorem proving at a higher level
than just going then reducing it then
grinding everything down to the axioms
of set theory right you're doing a kind
of more synthetic
mode of reasoning I could just say is
house dorf and conclude a bunch of
things without needing to actually be
able to generate set theory proofs
because I know the ontology of these
properties
right but this is captured you have a
way of capturing this which is sort of
your set of implications from these
properties
which is yet a separate way of thinking
about how to store the scholarship of
knowledge
yeah like the normal equivalent to being
T1 and T4
that kind of thing
I understand but this is a set of
implications so so what we've got
is
we've got the category Theory way of
thinking about it we've got the set of
pure implications between properties
and we've got the low level kind of
algebraic way of thinking about it in
terms of raw you know variables and
axioms of set theory and so on so that
the first statement what's the
relationship between this level of
implications between properties uh and
the category Theory level
I mean I can say it for a third time but
like the these can be captured as
universal properties and then one can
deduce relationships between those
Universal properties right so the idea
would be to the the the the the the
again the reason I the we had this
meeting uh Ian Jack and I had this
meeting was to discuss whether whether
it was feasible to be able to deduce
these you know this collection of of
implications that essentially that graph
even was showing uh was representing
from the underlying category theoretic
representation of these things when you
said Universal Property in
that was the dotted line thing in yes
yeah the the analog of universally and
existentially Quantified propositions
so like in that nlab article you can see
the t0 T1 T2 T3 T4
um separation axioms encoded as those
Universal properties in top
okay but when you say I mean just to my
understanding so there's morphisms which
are solid arrows and there's Universal
properties which you're saying are like
that except they're dotted arrows well
no the dotted out the dashed arrows as
we saw before are the existentially the
unit uniquely existentially Quantified
morphisms in that picture no I get it
but from a graph Theory point of view we
are adding in certain
dotted lines
properties that don't have existential
quantifiers in them you can have
Universal quantifiers just pure
Universal quantifiers
yeah I think there's more I need to
understand here but I'd like to but I
mean so the bottom line here might be
that using for example the things
already curated for the pure math
framework it might be possible to make
an assertion
in terms of
uh
um
you know in terms of those properties
that Ian was showing there
and prove some assertion
that is not deducible purely from the
implications that are listed in you know
that Ian has already curated is that is
that a correct statement or even just to
just to be able to validate the ones
that already you know automatically
generated generate the ones that are
already there even if we don't discover
new ones it'd be nice to have some way
of
right so so this graph is from the point
of view of I just curated all of these
I I just trust that these are true I I
don't have proofs for any of these right
and then I want to do and then I want to
prove things about particular spaces
given this huge collection okay so your
claim as yeah this thing is a path
toward actually being able to to prove
things like this and maybe even because
some sometimes I'll try to figure out is
a space para compact
um when I know that it's countably para
Compact and I won't have a theorem for
that that might be a path if we had
Universal no so okay so you're saying
given the definition of top the category
definition of top and given I don't know
how these properties are defined in
terms of of top for example you know is
Lindelof does that turn into some whole
sort of statement in terms of morphisms
and things inside top how does that work
yeah let me let me pull that up
oh so it is already yeah
yeah I think it had one F I think it has
one f
I think it has one f
I mean I just bled it off that other
place so
okay but so that's fine that's in words
but can we can we see that in more
oh wow okay
so yeah it's for every object in the
category
you make some statement about it
and the claim is it's open covered
say it again
the claim is that this could instead be
written as a universal property
instead of in terms of like these are
all basically set theory constructions
but that label is open cover of is that
being defined by this statement or is
that have to have some other stuff
concept is open cover of
this is what it means to be an open
cover
you have a collection of open sets whose
Union is the
okay so the certain base Concepts here
and all those base Concepts somehow
defined in the category top or other
base Concepts that have to be introduced
no as I say because these can all be
represented purely as universal
properties so like an open cover is just
an epymorphism with some
uh coheritance conditions
um okay okay and and what I have now top
itself is defined in terms of set theory
which is itself not defined by this
project
I understand so just just so I'm
understanding how things fit together I
mean in the in the kind of um uh proof
assistant world and the homotopic type
Theory world how does this relate to
what we're talking about here
what we're talking about here is
encoding you're saying category
repository okay and it seems like we've
got a couple of components here we've
got a category repository that has the
definitions of these categories we've
then got Ian's thing which is defining a
bunch of human relevant properties which
can be ultimately defined in terms of
the The Primitives of those categories
is that is that a fair characterization
yeah but obviously that should be part
of the category repository I mean just
having a pure abstract category is not
super useful no I understand okay so
category repository plus the properties
the human defined properties I mean it's
just like an axiomatic Theory we have
the axioms and then we have
uh well we actually don't have we have
we have notable theorems for example but
we could have constructs that are
defined in terms of the underlying
operators
that makes sense
basically all of these are just
constructions that are ultimately built
up using combinations of like set
builder set Union like set theory
constructs
yeah these are these are all definitions
and theorems in the in set theory
the way they're uh done now
I get it but the basic point is that you
know sort of operationally there'll be a
category repository that contains also
for these categories just like we have
like notable theorems in the axiomatic
Theory place
um so similarly here we would have sort
of note of interesting properties
that will be defined in terms of the raw
material of those categories is that
right
I think so that'll be the Hope okay and
just to give me a sense of scale in
terms of the number of I I hate to ask
these kinds of matter questions but in
terms of the you know in typical pure
math are there like a hundred categories
that people commonly use I mean I know
there are ones that I hear about
repeatedly but I mean are there if you
don't what what's the what's the rough
size of this category Repository
my estimate which is a very rough one is
that if we had on the order of 20 to 30
we could cover 95 percent of cases okay
it's set top vect uh group AB
D Hill you know they're they're a
handful right but it's not okay so it's
it's comparable to axiomatic Theory then
I think so I I mean like
it's much less diverse than axiomatic
Theory
in because why
but because almost all of these are
really almost all the categories I've
just described are Concrete in the
category theoretic sense and that they
are all uh equipped with some faithful
functor to set so they're you know each
one you can think of as being like set
so some forgetful content to set you can
think of each one as being just set with
some additional structure
um whereas axiomatic Theory supports a
fairly oh the aim was always to support
a fairly diverse collection of of axioms
right so okay so I mean in terms of this
this project you know it seems like a
good Next Step will be to try and Define
that category uh Repository
yeah absolutely
okay and then the
and the end result of that would be that
one should be able to enter some
statement in terms of the properties
that are defined in that category
repository and then automated theorem
proving should be able to Crunch through
well you should be able to both
enumerate things that are true in a
given category
and also you should be able to actually
just find a path from one statement to
other statements and thereby I mean what
does a proof look like in the category
Theory world
what is the what is the presentation of
a proof in the category Theory world
oh Wildcats has 29 categories that's
that's what Nick is pointing out so yeah
so 20 to 30 is probably not a bad
estimate good okay
uh but no anyway so what a proof looks
like depends on there there are many I
mean but
uh
logic
a large class of proofs effectively boil
down to these commutative diagram
pictures right that you can you
essentially just you know you give some
coherence condition and the proof is
literally witness uh you know a
particular collection of compositions of
morphisms you say these morphisms exist
and how would we present that proof
I mean that's that's a separate question
I I mean
but can you completely give a path or
something to represent that proof
yeah well I mean composition of
morphisms is a path right
but so you you'd be giving up you'd be
witnessing a collection of pods
and relations between those parts I'm
gonna go ahead and stop sharing
um
okay but so so okay so just like with
fine equational proof where it's a
little bit you know unclear and
hopefully we're working towards having a
better you know truly computable
representation of the proof object this
again is a little bit meta in terms of
what the proof object is
so the first statement
I think so I mean but that's fine I mean
that but but the but the important point
is in this case one can both enumerate
everything that's you know when we just
start grinding out sort of everything
that's true and that reminds me a bit
uh
well I mean obviously we've done that
for the these equational kinds of things
but isn't it in in our geometry project
don't we similarly have a okay let's
just ask the question the kind of
proving that's going on here how does it
relate maybe Ian can say this to our
geometry project
or is it just is that totally a
different idea
so
there's currently no released proving in
the geometry project Peter Behrens is
working on find geometric proof which is
very similar to find equational proof
how does it work roughly I mean does it
turn things into algebra
I'm not exactly sure
like side angle side
congruence and things like that
geometric proof essentially uses
it's it's very much more like will from
alpha show steps it uses human readable
you know human comprehensible steps it
doesn't boil everything down to some
automatable language
okay fair enough
okay
uh okay the questions here
about so okay so first point is with
respect to this abstract category
framework you are fairly well Advanced
although it doesn't look like you've
done you've started to do these um uh
monoidal category type things well well
abstract monotone category currently
does a lot of stuff that's that's one
I've spent a decent fraction of the last
several months working on wow um
um
those pictures a little hard to
understand oh my gosh what on Earth is
all of this
oh my
God did this look familiar yes
I don't understand them but but they
they are bird tracks or Penrose blobs or
ZX diagrams or tensor networks depending
on who you ask
well that's very interesting
so all of the you know projects notation
Panera's notation
um
or you know all of the the ZX calculus
limitation they are all effectively
special cases of string diagram notation
in monoidal category Theory and so so
abstract trigma nodal category has a
general way of manipulating string
diagrams so if these were if these were
morphisms in the category of finite
dimensional Hilbert spaces then we'd get
exactly Penrose graphical notation if
they're morphisms in sorry in in just in
the category of Hilbert spaces in
general if they were in the category of
finite dimensional herbal spaces we'd
get ZX diagrams if they were in the
category of uh say a billion groups and
their representations we'd get blood
track notation okay so can you can you
walk through roughly what an earth these
are what is was the simplest case of
this
yeah so all you're doing is you're
taking a category and you're equipping
it with a with a tensor product right
you're equipping it with a memorial
structure yep and so what that what that
represents concretely is you're
equipping it with a buy functor that is
to say you're equipping it with a
functor from the product category with a
so if you've got a category C you can
take the product category C Cross C like
a sort of which acts like a kind of
Cartesian product right so you're taking
you're treating hair wise objects and
pairwise morphisms uh and if you have a
monoidal if you have a bifunction i a
functor from C Cross C to C that
satisfies uh uh as a certain set of um
uh coherence conditions Associated and
left and right unit are coherence
conditions that effectively says the
tensor product operation is associative
and uh unit or has an identity then you
get a monoidal category right so it's a
it's a category equipped with this with
this additional bi-functor
okay so here in particular you've got
this category set up I think I I love
the fact that we can just type stuff in
it's actually okay great okay so this is
some category here I think I understand
what that is now you've got the the
product the tensor product category
presumably that's this category C Cross
C here is that right yeah so the left
hand side so that that the left-hand
side of that functor over there in input
25 is the product category
kind of thought
okay and this Maps down to a single copy
of the category is that right yes so
right now you can see it's obviously not
equivalent to the original one and
that's a sign that the the right now
this monado category is under specified
that you'd need to impose some
additional mappings between objects and
morphisms in order to have this be a
valid monodo category okay so this is
y cross y
maps to y z Cross C maps to Z yes X
cross X we haven't defined
and then of course then there are some
equivalences that are defined purely by
the axioms of category by the axioms of
monogate theory so if you asked for
Associated equations and left and right
units are equations you'd get um lists
of equations imposed just by the axis of
no categories okay so so here this is a
representation of this product category
right so exactly so well it's a
representation of the monoidal structure
so string diagrams were essentially
invented precisely because the ordinary
when you start dealing with monado
categories
the ordinary categorical diagrams become
incomprehensible right they're way too
large way too complicated so string
diagrams are a way of of nicely
representing decomposing the structure
of morphisms in a monoidal category
okay so here you can see so this is an
association so you so you can see okay F
cross f is amorphism
and then you can see it maps to a list
and these and this is giving a list of
all equivalent ways you could represent
that morphism in string diagrams
so the first diagram there is saying f f
tensor F Maps X tensor X if you take the
object X tends to X and you apply F
tensor F you get y tensor y
but you could also and then the the
remaining elements of the list are
saying that's also equivalent to taking
X tensor X applying identity X tensor F
so you get X tensor Y and then applying
F tensor identity Y and you get y tensor
y it's the same you know same result
I see so these this is putting in a
thing in its inverse here yeah
uh no it's it's a it's it's identity
what do you mean so the but this little
bead here on this on this line
is I mean why couldn't I not put three
beads on the line as well oh yeah you
could you could okay so this is just the
first level of of one level beading so
to speak yeah yeah of course you could
you could compose in sequence as many
identity operations as you wanted
okay
and this is showing
so this is showing for composition so
here you've got identity X tensor G
compose f
and there's only one way of representing
that here
what's the tilde thingy
identity what does that mean
the identity morphism on object X okay
all right fine
I see I see so that's this piece here
and then
f
so yeah so so G compose f is just that
thing right you you're playing F then
you're playing G
okay I get it and so if yeah if we were
in the if we were in the monoidal
category of finite dimensional Hilbert
spaces then the tensor product structure
is the tensor product of Hilbert spaces
and then each one of these boxes is just
um a matrix and then each one of these
wires is some vector
okay and then you get a ZX diagram
that's cool
um and then yeah so if you scroll down
you can see there are you know here's a
non-trivial example now you've got
actual kind of gluings between stuff
right so now we've in this version of
the monundo category we we've called F10
to F big F
and so now it's it's it whereas before
we had like two-legged spiders now we've
got a four-legged spider we've got X
tensor X goes into a big F and it
outputs y tensor Y and then you can
Plumb those together in various ways and
so you can build up by taking these
tensor products you can build up spiders
with arbitrary numbers of legs and you
can do index contraction and essentially
so strict monitor category also includes
as a special case essentially just a
general method of manipulating tensors
like abstract symbolic tenses
but so what's happening here is
you had had previously that that out of
you know that pure product
and this is now saying this is a mixing
thing that is combining uh these these
elements right yeah so if actually if
you scroll up just a little bit you can
see how it's defined
um
so here in in the definition of a
monoidal category we've said yeah F
tensor F goes to big F
G tensor G goes to Big G Etc okay okay
and that's that's what's being reflected
there and so then so then you can yeah
and the once you've got these spiders
with more than two legs you you know
there are different ways you can you can
Plumb them together
okay and so this is ultimately going to
okay so well this is interesting and I
I'm lovely and needs I need to
understand it
um but when we think about this
concretely where these functions f and g
are actual you know wolfen language
functions yes is this a way so so the
monoidal structure is what turns
multi-way systems into single-way
systems right
because effectively what you're doing
when you take a monoidal product is
you're saying okay we've got these two
computations that could be performed in
parallel
so I okay suppose you've got the
situation where you you've got some
multi-way system you've got a branch
that takes you from X to Y and you've
got another branch that takes you from Z
to w
ow you could think of that you could
apply those two branches in parallel
those two Evolution edges in parallel
but you could think of that as being a
single operation applied to uh X tensor
Z
which then yields uh y tensor w right
so it's almost like I mean these things
are if the if the if the things were
like this where they're running
separately so to speak
there's no synchronization defined for
those they just they're just separate
things whereas here you're saying they
have to go into this mixer and be
processed together to produce a result
is that right right exactly and so in
the in terms of the multi-way structure
this this is precisely what gives rise
to things like entanglement right this
is what gives rise to non-trivial
bronchial structure yep
yep
okay so but but what does that mean
okay so let's say we're doing power
computation by the way I mean I do I
again want to plug this you know I think
this is not a terrible way of doing
symbolic I know there's like
disagreements about how symbolic tenses
and things should be handled I think
this is not but I personally think this
is not a terrible way of doing it
um what does it it
what's the it here I mean so we've got
tensors you know T Alpha Beta gamma yeah
times you beta gamma Epsilon or
something so each one of these blobs is
a tensor right every Inc every input
wire is a is a contravariant index every
output wire is a covariant index and
then the rules of how they compose are
precisely the which which strict mode
Academy knows and you know has the
ability to manipulate are just the rules
of tensor algebra right so index
contraction is taking one of these wires
and plugging it into it you know if you
contract along the first and third
indices or something that what that
means is you're taking the Third
wire which will be an output wire
covariant index and you're plugging it
into the first wire which will be an
input wire a contravariant Index right
by the way a practical point is that I
mean these in terms of these graphs this
again requires labeled ports in these
graphs
right
which we still don't really have I mean
maybe Roger can comment on this
um this is yet another place where we're
going to need that oh Roger disappeared
um
okay but so in terms of thinking about
this and we should wrap up for today
soon but this is really really cool and
really cool
um
what
uh
okay just
if we think about these as actual
concrete functions
okay look tenses if there's a concrete
go ahead should I should I share and
just show the the concrete functionality
yes yes please do uh
so
if I okay what's your favorite function
on uh let's let's say your favorite
multi-way system on numbers
uh two hash one plus hash
okay so let's do
uh let's run that for two steps to begin
with
okay so this is now a way of rather than
specifying the arrows of equivalent
directly right this is a way of
generating arrows for quiver as just a
multi-way system right
okay
so we're taking you know one plus hash
applied to four or whatever uh and then
we can take this and we can use that as
the basis for you know the skeletal
basis of a category
maybe that's okay let's do two steps to
begin with and make it a little bit
easier
so this is now the category form of that
if we ran the the same multi computation
for three steps we'd get a more
complicated looking category structure
what answers are we going to get here is
it going to be the same
because this is
oh gosh what are we seeing here is this
I mean this is just a multi-way system
isn't it maybe do the reducer no because
it was because it was the transitive
reduction transitive closure of a
multi-way system
I mean usually in our multi-way systems
we're showing the transit reduction
right
right we could show the transit of
closure okay which is what one nice
thing about this is for instance we
could take that and we can say
just like we can so all the
functionality from abstract category
carries over into concrete category
along with some other there's some
additional stuff so we could say what
are the commutativity equations so these
are now statements in
goal from language that effectively are
uh correct you know statements about
correctness of function composition
right so if I took this
I think if I just say activate
where the left and right sides of those
equals just composition are they
actually oh they're actually applied to
things like of one and so on so they're
applied to the initial condition in the
end right uh wait I mean again you could
specify multiple initial conditions if
you wanted
just just for visual sake because you
tried doing one of the getting one of
the reduced graphs
uh yes although I mean wait do you want
reduced or do you want simple
I think um I think I want reduced just
like the transition the reduced labeled
graph is going to be the same because
there are no equivalences but what you
could do what you may want is reduced by
these commutativity equations
uh so if I do that
I meant more if there was a way of
visualizing the transitive reduction I
mean in categories do people always draw
the composition edges or do they but the
trends the production is the transitive
reduction is the quiver
oh I I see okay yeah sure
yeah
go ahead you can always get the
underlying quiver from any category is
the quiver always the quiver isn't
always minimal though right like you
could have or is it
um no I guess the quiver doesn't know
you know you you can't specify in one of
these Quivers that you know this Edge is
the composition of these two other edges
right right
okay fine yeah yeah you can't so there's
no canonical minimized form it's what
you're claiming
I I don't think that can be because yeah
you you to do that you need to have a
notion of composition on the arrows of
equivalent which you don't have
okay so in other words the the okay but
so now
all right so this is
one of those fun things about this is
that that then means that we can use the
automated theorem prover in the you know
the minimal the the sort of mini
automated theorem prover in abstract
category we can use that to prove
theorems about Wolfram language
functions from language code
like in this case it's a pretty trivial
collection of theorems but you could
imagine proving kind of some more
interesting things but involving
Universal quantifiers and stuff like
that
so wait a minute so we've got morphisms
here which are just random functions I
mean in this case two hash one plus hash
well they're not the morphisms they're
the generators of the morphisms right
I see in in this category the morphisms
are arbitrary are pure functions that
can be constructed by arbitrary
compositions of those generators
so okay so that's sort of a multi-way
okay so that that's like
this is
multi-weighing with the generators f and
g so to speak
just like we could Nest list for the
generated g f or something right right
and now but you're saying a program
are you saying that there is the analog
of a program an arbitrary program as
opposed to a nestless constructive
program
that would have these different arrows
labeled
at the programmer's whim so to speak
uh no it's more than a program so I mean
essentially you could imagine building
each one of these we one can think of as
being a subcategory of some category of
Wolfram language expressions whose
morphisms are pure functions right
sure and the point is that that any
arbitrary program is just an is an edge
in that graph right any arbitrary
program is just a
functional program is just an edge in
that graph
foreign
in the graph wait a minute that
this is an infinite category of an open
language expressions and you're saying
when we draw
this diagram
we
every possible transformation
corresponds to a so that transformation
might involve huge amounts of gnashing
of teeth to get from one expression to
another
but in this rather traditional
mathematical way we're just saying
that's just a that's amorphism boom it
happens right because the transitive
closure essentially hides all the
details of the computational complexity
but in transitive closure is the enemy
of computational irreducibility right
right
um hence James's summer school project
from last year but
okay but so
we could imagine something where we have
restricted the set of morphisms to not
be arbitrary programs but to be some
subset of programs
right
perhaps generated in some way like the
ones here
in
now one question then
is you know functors between those
morphisms
do we have any idea what on Earth those
are
well there are two levels of that
question right there's there are high
amorphisms between the between the one
morphisms and they're also the functors
between the categories
fine
okay so the higher morphisms between
these morphisms are essentially
equivalences between programs
not necessarily equivalences I mean this
is one of the reasons why I was kind of
interested to see what James was doing
with end machines right because that's
kind of from my limited understanding
that's what an end machine is it's
supposedly some way of translating from
you know a pure function in this
category to another pure functions in
this category
James can you say something about that
I'm still not sure I'm not treating it
necessarily categorically it's more of
taking univalent foundations and just
focusing on the program's part and
having a way of computationally treating
higher Hama topics between programs in
the really ad basically that's something
that Jonathan and I should discuss is
how to
the extent to which it should be made
categorical because I even think in the
foundations of univalent Foundations
there could have different degrees to
which people actually explore the kind
of category part of the of the Trinity
so to speak
all right so so I'm sorry but the point
is I think Jonathan's point is that
there's a difference between punctuality
and say hamotape equivalence for
instance those things are distinct
and
there's a lot of complex or just between
the difference between factoriality and
equivalence as well but look all that's
all that I'm saying is that there's a
difference between compilation which is
what the functor is and program to
program transformation which is what the
high amorphisms are foreign I'm not
saying anything particularly more fancy
than that okay compilation or
interpretation being from one category
from one class of of Expressions to
another so you can imagine building
you can imagine versions of these
concrete categories for different
programming languages right or for
Turing machines versus cellular
automators yeah yeah exactly different
models of computation and if they're all
the if they're all equivalent as models
of computation then at the very least
they should preserve compositional
structure sure which means there should
be homomorphisms between those
categories I.E there should be
functionality
um that's really what compilation is
um Although seeing that explicitly it
will be a little bit more fancy than
that because there'll be things like
I mean the representation of States
there'll be questions about equivalences
between different representations of
states
where two states might have different
forms but they might be equivalent Etc
et cetera et cetera I think it's a
little bit more tricky oh sure no I mean
and you know this came up in the summer
school a bunch of times about like
State equivalence is kind of a really
crucial thing in these you know what
what your state equivalence function is
is a very very model dependent or what
the reasonable State equivalent function
is it's a very very model dependent
question yeah and no doubt Observer
dependent also because that's that's
ultimately what you know at some level
every multi-way graph is just a tree if
it wasn't for State equivalence
right
um but but okay just just trying to map
out objectives here
this thing with with wolfen language
expressions
I mean
do we imagine okay what is the evaluator
in terms of this
I'm just confused about how this fits in
to how we think about
maybe does Nick have any thoughts about
this Nick has been working on some
related multi-computation ideas
Perhaps Perhaps not
well those those generators are like
why can you create your rule
you can yeah
so all computational models can be
looked at those generators
doesn't have to be pure function it can
be just apply a negle writing rule
yes
but my question is how does this fit in
I mean if if we were going to go it has
to be a pure function in the sense that
it can't have side effects if it has
side effects then your function
composition is not necessarily
associated
sure and you yeah
yeah is that and move from language is
more natural to look at competitions
just through writing and not the
applying a function because we're
writing is even more pure than actual
pure function I I yeah I don't disagree
with that
right but so so how would we use this I
mean what would be a I mean and how
in terms of okay so let's say we have
models that are multi-computational
models
can we use this to understand more about
those models or
where does this get used yeah and use
the proof theorems about them we can use
them you know you can take some
multi-way system and you can actually
generate the monoidal category that it
corresponds to and you could do
reasoning about that monotone category
and you can do tensor manipulations in
that monado category so what's an
example something you might conclude
from that
thank you
uh uh depend I mean that's a very
general question well I mean like for
example you might prove some theorem
that you know I don't know the branchial
space is always bounded in some way or
something I don't know I mean what what
types of things could you imagine
establishing
well I mean for instance prove it you
know establishing that for instance a
given multi-computation generates a
monoidal category with a you know with a
certain dagger structure or that has
compact closeness or um that AP you know
a particular graphy writing rule
generates a topos or what like I mean
these are all things that are obviously
interesting and relevant to a bunch of
physics project stuff
indeed very much so
so what do we how what do you mean by
proving that it generates a top us what
would be what would be the sort of
payoff from that
I'm asking these really naive questions
because I'm still struggling with this
whole area but go ahead
well I mean if we ensure that it
generates a topos then we can show for
instance that it's a reasonable basis
for metamatics
that's one obvious thing another thing
is that you know we if we can show that
it's a growth in deep top boss then it
means it has a spatial structure and
that means that uh you know if we if we
have a way of proving that then it's a
way of getting spatiality without the
need to prove that a Continuum limit
exists
um
yeah so how so how plausible is it to do
those kinds of things I think quite
plausible
um I mean right now we like in the in
the rather currently rather embryonic
implementation of abstract topos there
is code for you know for testing and
proving whether an arbitrary category is
a top loss
sorry sorry I I got distracted for a
second could you say that again
so I mean I I have an embryonic uh
implementation of abstract topos which
Builds on the abstract limit framework
uh that has functionality for
determining whether an arbitrary
abstract category is atop us and proving
that it is if it if you know for
actually witnessing the finite limits
and actually witnessing the sub-object
classifier in the case where it is
so I think it's quite plausible I mean
there's actually the code already exists
it's just not deployed yet
there's a lot of cool stuff here all
right we ran way over time
um
what's the I'm still not fully absorbing
this
uh I think maybe I have to actually play
with it to absorb it some more I mean it
doesn't help there's just this giant you
know Festival of of weird epimorphism
retraction whatever things that I don't
know why one cares about so to speak
um
I mean just for context I mean all of
those things are basically taking
standard intuitions that one has about
functions and you know making the work
in the more General context of morphisms
right so epimorphisms monomorphisms
bimorphisms are just essentially the
Notions of injectivity surge activity
and bijectivity yes fraction sections
isomorphisms just left right inverses
and left and right emphasis yes
Etc
I mean yeah this okay other comments
from people here about sort of how this
fits into bigger pictures
um I mean just sorry here's a naive
questions like when you have instead of
generators you have a typography right
here low and you get a concrete query
from those would it induce a typographic
category with all those spans cost plans
Ah that's an interesting question yeah
so
probably not I I'm
so hypergraph categories are not
categories of as you're aware like
hypograph categories are not categories
of hypographs they're category they're
monoidal categories whose string
diagrams are hypographs
um yeah I don't think it's a priority
obviously that the category generated by
a hypography writing rule would
necessarily be a hypograph category
yeah
probably
I think it's just a I think it's a name
Collision
um every pun that's going to be proved
yeah anyway what I was going to say was
I mean the main reason I wanted to have
this meeting was it feels like you know
that okay there's the pure math packlet
there's the multi-computation stuff
there's also I mean
I don't know what the long-term plans
for graphy writing in the language are
but for instance you know because we
have things like pullbacks and push-outs
we can construct push out compliments we
can build DPO systems
um in this framework
and so again like that's that's if there
is going to be a general implementation
of graphic writing in the language it
feels like that should probably be
integrated
um so and and as I say there's you know
there's there's the implementation of
these monodo categories we've got these
string diagrams that are really just ZX
diagrams they're really just you know
for the case of fdhill they are just
specifications of quantum circuits so it
feels like there's potential integration
there and my concern is I don't want to
develop these things too far
but you know without at least touching
base about like I agree I agree because
it'd be nice to have this as a
foundation you know for thinking about
all of those different kinds of things
but it just I mean it would really be
helpful
something that I'm just not getting
right now
is you know how you think about
you know this is look one thing that I
have long considered really long
considered ridiculously long considered
is how do you turn graphs into functions
right
and
you know by essentially making their
edges do something
and this is a version of doing that
right
and in a sense a lot of the fancy stuff
that's going on here is things like
how do you think about composing you
know functions represented by graphs and
stuff like this I think and that's
essentially what you're how do you think
about taking products of well products
as in tuples of
uh right yep functions represented by
graphs
um
it's it's an irritating Quirk of
terminology that product categories and
categorical products are very different
things
um
product categories are like the tuples
case categorical products of these weird
Universal Property things that are
unrelated
okay does anybody else have uh anybody
else want to offer yeah can I ask do you
have a way of getting the
um terminal object in a category yes
Implement so so in abstract category uh
we build a category with a terminal
object uh
Y is a terminal object
cool it's also a strict terminal object
and
Etc
so
one idea is that things like fold can be
characterized as
um
morphisms from an initial object in a
category that's defined by an endo
functor
the idea of a catamorphism
and The Duel of that is nest and that's
basically what I used to
understand Nest tree and tree fold
so
I think I'm going to explore that a
little bit
so you think I mean your implication
there is there might be generalizations
of those things that are sort of
evaluation operations on graphs for
example yeah so there's like the
category of Wolfram language patterns
this is like above you have like the
objects are particular Expressions I was
thinking about the case where the
objects are patterns
and the endo functor
that I'm referring to is the idea of
like a function signature
so for example tree takes two arguments
the data and a list of trees and that
can be expressed as an endo functor and
from that you can have a Constructor
basically for trees by having
um you look at the the terminal object
the or the final object would be like
the object that represents all possible
trees
and so you can Nest tree is is basically
the thing that constructs the morphism
to that final object and tree fold is
the thing that can that starts with the
initial object which is trees and
applies an operator so I wonder if
there's a way to generalize that
yeah
yeah that's kind of interesting
all this type classes when the derived
foldable type Quest reversible type
Quest when it also comes from this
monoi time crosses
so it's basically a generalization so
all these kind of nests and faults can
be also be generated with
like what
well just uh Haskell people like the
stuff they all like category Theory and
to Define their functions and type
courses and they have this special type
causes for foldable that data structure
traversable data structure
and they basically do the similar stamp
there
okay
foreign
Christopher Mano James
I think so I I did just want to mention
actually one one other
um in terms of the applicability to the
multi-computations
uh okay hang on for some reason this
documentation page is loading extremely
slowly there we go uh is we do have
support for vibration checking I mean so
actually it's one of the things like I
kind of wanted to work with Mano on at
some point
um is getting the vibration stuff
more fully featured I'm sure I have yeah
here we go okay so here we have a way of
determining we can test whether
um whether a given functor is a valid
discrete vibration of categories we can
you know we can actually compute what
the individual fibers are if it is you
know in the case where it is a growth
and deep vibration Etc
and so there are things there are things
situations where for instance we could
actually go and concretely prove for a
given ruly or multi-way system that
individual multi-way systems correspond
to you know to specific fibers uh that
you know the the
um decomposition into individual multi
overall multi-way system into individual
multi-way systems is a valid grotonic
vibration
um that's also something which in
principle would be supported by the
abstract functor framework and the
concrete functor framework as it's
currently developed
um so it seems to me one thing we're
useful here I mean this is a more of a
research type thing
um as a lot of this is uh
is
I mean just taking some things that
we've done with string multi-way systems
and just seeing how that works
in the setup
or seeing what one can establish there
sure um and and but as I say the nice
thing is that a bunch of these kind of
currently a bit more
um
loose ideas about
um vibrations and foliations and things
in arbitrary multi-way systems we can
actually you know once once we have a
way of representing concrete functors we
can actually just go and explicitly
compute you know what are the vibrations
um
yes I understand
I think I need to understand this better
I think we need to I need to Crunch on
it a bit and then we need to have
another discussion because I think I
mean look design wise this looks
reasonably nice I mean quite nice I you
know I had micro comments like you
shouldn't call something blah blah blah
objects or whatever they are and then
have a list of things that say fro true
Gro false type thing yeah it's the um
maybe that's more like the indicator or
something or it needs a name that is you
know because it's basically like a set
where you're giving an you know and
whatever they're called indicator
function on the set or something I I
agree so I mean right now the fact that
same monomorphisms returns an
association whose values are booleans I
agree is kind of weird
um I initially thought about calling it
like monomorphism Q or something but
that seemed even no that's that's more
even more bizarre
um
I mean monomorphism information is also
rather silly I I don't have an
immediately better suggestion I mean it
is if I understand correctly in set
theory that would be called an indicator
function yes right yep there
um not that that's necessarily a good
name uh
that was that's one thing I noticed I
mean other than that really looks quite
um and the visual appearance of these
diagrams
and I think
you know things like that composition
operator you know does have to be
somewhat standardized because that
composition operator is going to get
used all over the place and it's going
to get used if I understand correctly it
really should be something which can be
interpreted as an actual composition
operator in the case of Orphan language
functions well I mean that's why in the
concrete category case we do actually
use
um where is it yeah we do actually use
add star
I see
I see so but the the concept is that
there's kind of a a um an abstracted at
Star and then there's the I mean it's
you might claim it's a little bit like
single equals versus double equals
and although I don't know that's really
the right way to think about it one of
them is a kind of a an abstract
composition and the other is an actually
do it composition yeah I I would think
of it more as like the formal formal
operators that we use in axiomatic
Theory
yes like you you have plus which
actually does which actually has
semantics and then you have some kind of
formal plus which is just defined by
some algebraic axioms
yes which is not a super satisfactory
dichotomy
no
um
but I mean so this has that same issue
that it has the
the
I mean in a sense like an axiomatic
Theory we have sort of this notion of
maybe we don't touch so we have sort of
yeah I mean we could have sort of the
common interpretations thing somehow in
the category
I don't know that makes sense
uh
all right there's more to figure out
here
um I'm supposed to go to some completely
different meeting but this is uh it's
really very nice stuff it's great I mean
I and and um uh so there's a lot of
these things that are already in there
as function repository as released
function repository entries
and there are others that are in the
works
um I really think it will be useful to
start thinking about this category
repository because I think that will
give you the ability to have many good
examples here
and also the ability to understand so it
seems to me like encoding the first few
of those categories set top whatever
else
um
uh
I do love the way that you know in a oh
no we're not doing computation here the
category theorists name their things
after kind of primitive variable names
right right the
um it does rather beg the question of
whether we should use wolf to denote the
category I mean because in effect this
is so this is some subcategory of the
category of Wolfram language expressions
and morphisms yeah I should call it wolf
just in order to be to fit in with the
absurdity of um uh of the um I like that
idea
um because ordinarily concrete
categories were defined over set right
you you say you say a concrete a
category is concrete if it's an abstract
category but it also has some forgetful
functor to set
but because sets are quite alien to the
language it feels much more natural to
have this be the the kind of the base
category right yes I agree
um
but I think
right but that means that in the
category repository we could imagine
there are certain properties of the wolf
category so to speak and there will be
some categories that are mappable in
this forgetful functor type way to the
wolf category like some sub languages
like some particular provable thing with
with you know lists and reverse and and
take and first and last and Etc and
append and so on because imagine some
right right exactly and and so you you
could you could even imagine cons I mean
this would give you a kind of Fairly
systematic way of constructing fully
formalizable semantic semantics for
um fragments of the Wolfram language
right you you could imagine construct
some as you you know as you say uh you
can imagine building some fragment for
instance based on list operations where
you could actually prove correctness uh
you know of of all programs or something
yeah those fragments won't be terribly
big no no of course yeah
okay but I mean so so look at concrete
things you know the construction of the
category repository seems like a highly
worthwhile thing and you know just like
we have
axiomatic Theory
um you know
uh
we probably need
category data or something
well one question is should this be part
of the pure math packlet or do you
envision something separate
I think they should be sort of separate
initially but then expect to have
cross-connections emerging because the
pure math packlet already has lots of
design that may or may not be consistent
with this
or what do you think in
from my end I think that there's
there's very few properties currently
for category entities so
the design is pretty much wide open
about what kind of properties you want
categories to have
I think for the sake of just the process
of doing this we should build it
separately and then expect to knit it
together
it's really rather exciting I mean you
know because it as
you know I mean do we think we will
actually be able to do practical
pure math
with this of that is non-trivial
interest in pure math
with these things
I I certainly think so
um so you think that the the the that
sort of exercises in a topology book
might be doable with this well actually
I mean that's one of the things that
um
okay it's one of the things that Yorick
and I were talking about the other day
about as a possibility of going through
I mean we actually discussed that
precise example of going through a
graduate level like algebraic topology
course and figuring out how we would
encode like the exercises in this CT
framework because all you know all the
functionality exists to do that
um and basically you know
most of algebraic's apology at some
level you can reduce to diagram chasing
and homological algebra
um and you know we have very good
algorithms for doing that in this in the
CT framework so it
like I don't know I don't see any major
obstruction it's just there's some
there's a bit of translation that you
need to be able to build that take that
takes you from the topology Concepts to
you know abstract category Concepts but
that's okay
definitions and theorems for algebraic
topology
you said by the way and you you went
caved
um
my microphone away and forgot to move it
back um we had an intern curate theorems
and definitions in algebraic topology
what are those results
they're in the pure math packlet
but as Jonathan knows I mean that would
be that would seem like a great place to
start for this yeah I agree no it's it's
look at them but I don't think you'll
immediately like use the definitions and
theorems to do the project you were just
describing Jonathan
sure no but it's useful to look at I
agree
um
Jonathan maybe you're about to have
students and things who might be able to
contribute to this yeah I know that that
would be the hope that would be like you
could you could feed them I mean anybody
who's learning this stuff this is
probably a great way to to you know to
learn it is to actually do some of that
curation and so on
um but yeah I I I'm the reason I'm kind
of optimistic is because this is
you know there's
when you're dealing with proof
assistance and automated theorem
proofers there's a distinction between
whether you want your approver to be
axiomatic versus whether it should be
synthetic right like what do you want
things to grind down to the underlying
axioms of set theory or Boolean algebra
or whatever or do you want your approver
to operate at a synthetic level where
it's directly manipulating the relevant
Concepts
and the point is that category theory is
a very very good foundation for for
developing synthetic clear improvers
I mean that's kind of the lean principle
but
um
yeah I mean category theory is a pretty
good basis for that because what were
you saying about lean what
well I mean so lean uses type theory for
the same purpose
yes and in a I mean in a sense it's not
it's not normally how people talk about
this but in a sense they're using the
fact that there's this nice Duality
between Type Theory and category theory
that effectively every well every topos
you can think of as modeling as having
an internal logic that is some uh
dependent higher order type Theory and
vice versa
um
that's essentially what they're
exploiting
but the question of whether math you
know which kinds of math are more
naturally represented in terms of
categories versus more naturally
represented in terms of type Theory can
you characterize that
um well like I say I mean there isn't
really a distinction because you there's
a translate you can there's a pretty
direct translation from one to the other
I mean James already mentioned or at
least parenthetically mentioned
computational trinitarianism which is
sort of the basis of this idea right
that's one part of the Trinity is that
there's a direct translation from type
theories to categories
because for for any type for any higher
order dependent type Theory you can
build a top-offs whose internal logic
models that type Theory
um so there I don't think there is any
distinction between what branches of
mathematics are most naturally
formulated in types versus categories
because they're really equivalent
representations
right
well and um
okay and so yeah I mean the the idea
would be okay you know if you want to
prove something about topological spaces
in most cases it's easier to work at the
level of reasoning about continuous
functions and you know homeomorphisms
and things than is to reason at the
level of you know uh open sets and
neighborhoods and the underlying axioms
sure I mean yeah right so one question
is I mean from a science point of view
sort of bulking up this kind of stuff so
you've got you know we've got the
axiomatic level we've got sub axiomatic
levels we've got this level you're
calling it sort of the synthetic level
um and one could imagine the bulk
synthetic level just as we tried to
explore recently the bulk axiomatic and
sub-aximatic levels
so what is the bulk synthetic level
higher categories
something like that well I mean I get it
like usually if you're doing if you're
doing theorem proving or you're
developing a proof assistant you're not
you don't care about the whole category
right you you care about a specific
collection of paths
yes whereas the yeah the bulk theory is
the theory of the full category I would
argue yes okay fair enough
but then
right and there might be meta statements
to be made about that that uh go beyond
the statements made about individual
paths right and and the point is I mean
and this is kind of one of the ideas
behind which one of the reasons why
people get excited about homotopia type
theory is a basis for proof assistance
is because it's in general a lot easier
so to if you're reasoning at the
synthetic level it's generally a lot
easier to grind back down to the
actually to the axiomatic level if you
want to than to go in the other
direction right so uh if you see it's
not obvious that the swirling molecules
will actually form themselves into
vortices right exactly exactly but if
you if you've got the vortices you can
always you know look at them with a more
powerful microscope and then you know so
in homotopia type theory if you start
with a synthetic a purely synthetic
notion of a space you can always go back
but you know you can always pass to the
set of connected components or something
and recover the underlying set theory
but the point is you don't need to do
that you can you can reason just to the
level of the space
and there's a similar thing that happens
here
yes so if you wanted to you could you
know if we had a if you had a if we
developed a purely symbolic
representation of top which I think is
quite I mean as we've discussed I think
that is quite feasible to do then at any
point we could always in principle grind
down any theorem we've proved into
underlying axioms in terms of open sets
and neighborhoods but for the most part
you wouldn't care about that you could
just reason directly at the level of the
category
yes
and they were but but ultimately
there will be sort of undecidable things
at that level even though much of the
formalism including this whole
compositionality idea kind of denies the
possibility of that
and in a sense you know what woman has
to think about is math is ultimately
hard in some sense
and yet somehow that hardness is being
hidden here by among other things the
compositionality assumptions they're the
first statement yeah I think so I think
so which is why you know it'd be really
lovely to have a generalization of
category theory in which the you know
the edges in the transitive closure are
essentially tag there's some algebraic
relationship that tells you if I compose
this edge with this complexity in this
edge with this complexity we get a new
edge with some other you know some some
new complexity
right but what we'll see is if you do
things in this very compositional way
and you set up you know areas of
mathematics let's say we set up number
Theory this way okay it better be the
case
you know that there are difficult
problems in number Theory because
otherwise where are what would the
undecidability of this of the you know
solvability of some set of data python
equations what would that show up how
would that how would that
understandability show up in this
formulaism
well I mean the point is that because
we're operating at the synthetic level
there are two places where undecibility
can show up one is in the construction
of the morphisms themselves because
remember you know if we have a purely
symbolic description of one of these
categories then even constructing those
more you know if you recall the kind of
um symbolic description of top that Ian
was showing where you know you have the
is continuous function or whatever uh
determining that are you determining
whether a given morphism exists between
a pair of objects is itself a
computationally non-trivial operation so
even building up the category structure
itself can be undecidable then once
you're at the level of the category
because the morphisms themselves don't
you know because the the whole idea of
being able to take transitive closures
being able to do composition is itself a
kind of idealization a non-computational
idealization you can also get
undecidability creeping in at the level
of well if I take this infinite
composition of morphisms unless I have
some very very nice computational
complexity theoretic properties that
mean that the complexity of the
composition converges to some finite
value I can end up in the situation
where taking that composition is itself
undecidable
um yeah I mean I would kind of think
that in the standard formulation of
number Theory the first place would be
the place where things would get all
messed up
well I my view is a little different I
would say that because
the majority of undecidable problems
I should say independent problems that
have been discovered in mathematics have
been kind of engineered in a very
logician-esque way right they're things
like continual hypothesis or whatever
yeah except not the diphanton equations
right right well exactly but there are
some which seem much more like natural
mathematical problems and where you
could also prove undersettability Mike
injecture
based on just maybe this is bad mental
mathematical intuition is that the
former the you know the kind of
apparently engineered logicy ones are
cases where the undecidability is
creeping in at the microscopic level I
ate the level of actually constructing
the morphisms whereas the more naturally
occur the seemingly more naturally
occurring understandable problems are
ones in which the undecidability is
creeping in at the level of the morphism
composition because that's really
because it's it's at the level of the
morphism composition that most
mathematicians actually work right
um well okay so your statement there
would be the the natural ones are ones
which you get by taking Standard
Building Blocks and putting them
together and you have to have an
infinite number of those building blocks
to get to the answer or something
whereas in the other case you're saying
you have exotic building blocks like you
know the compilation of this statement
is unprovable type thing right exactly
exactly
and yeah my basis for saying that is
just that you know if category theory is
like the fluid dynamics and you know
axiomatic mathematics is like the
molecular Dynamics as mathematicians
work at the level of the fluid dynamics
applications that work the level of the
molecular no no that's that's a that's a
reasonable intuition
um
this is really interesting I mean I you
know it's still I yes I mean we you know
the other part of this is kind of the
from a language design point of view
understanding the stuff about
what on Earth you know well this thing
about
graphs as functions and Transformations
between functions and so on which I
still don't understand
but this is
and I really think
this formalism is going to force this
non-compositional view maybe more
quivery View
of what's going on because
because of the fact that you're just
sort of assuming answers and many in
many you know from a as we've said many
times here you know compositionality
you know assumes computational
reducibility
right right sure exactly yeah I mean in
a sense like you're receiving when you
take some big composition like this in a
concrete category you're assuming that
you can work out what the end point is
yep right
right yeah I mean one concern I have
there is there's all kinds of you know
irreducible and multi-computationally
reducible computations you know when
we're just dealing with basic really
at and that's where at least end machine
theory is supposed to make this
contribution where you're studying
within you know bounded time frames the
uh merging of the translation between
these different evaluation paths even if
you don't know ultimately what these
paths end up yielding either
behaviorally or whether they terminate
etc etc so there's there's some sort of
dance between the reducibility you can
yield and the bulk statements you can
yield
with category Theory where you actually
get end results and in terms of ruiology
in the study of the structure of the
rouliad when you don't know I mean some
of these rules are you know they they
don't end right but being able to say
something intelligent about higher
equivalences at least with time
boundaries between these different
evaluation paths
that's the kind of Distinction to me
it's like there are many in computer
science basically there are many cases
like finite State Finance automata where
things have been simplified enough that
they're decidable and that you can do
things with them you know my guess is
that category theory is another such
example where things have been kind of
simplified enough you can and you know
it's very useful to have these things
where they are decidable because you
know there's lots of engineering that
can be done with them Etc et cetera et
cetera they're not the rule illogical in
the wild version of things
sure I'm sure they're they're you know
they're well-developed colonies within
pockets of reducibility
right right but it might very well be
the case that if you
sort of remove a few assumptions there
particularly compositionality then uh
you know then suddenly this the whole
framework
becomes much more computational and gets
much you know more elaborate and uh uh
and so you know just like in a final
automaton you know the finiteness of the
finest automata and you know you take a
turing machine and you make it a finite
size tape you'll have a final automata
and uh you know in this case the
compositionality is some kind of
infinite okay claim that's some kind of
analog of finalization for like a turing
machine going to a final automaton and
but it is an infinite it's some kind of
less finite version of finalization
would be my claim you said
compositionality is less phonetization
than than something that's finite quite
because it's because you're composing
different things together
I'm not sure I mean it's because because
you're talking about categories that
could be infinite categories for example
they have compositionality yet the
category is infinite whereas in the case
of a turing machine with a finite tape
everything is finite there
that's why I'm saying that
in other words you've you've you've got
infinite numbers of objects but you
still have
sort of finiteness
I don't know
there's something you're saying it's
it's infinite in scope but because
ultimately everything you're working
with is reducible
that you're able to make some kind of
statements that are still infinite
statements but they're still ultimately
these kind of computationally reducible
statements yes that's true basically
what I'm saying so I mean I'm sure
there's an analog of that in for example
arithmetic and fragments arithmetic we
used to have an infinite number of I
mean you know any of these any of these
simplified versions of arithmetic
whether it's you know presbyter
arithmetic or whatever else simplified
version of arithmetic you've still got
an infinite number of integers but there
are you know the statements you can make
about them are always decidable
right right I'd like to see this you
know
comput computational version of category
Theory uh I mean I think Jonathan has
kind of hinted that this was something
that I was originally going to work on
but I think I've become much more
interested in the kind of ruliological
computation on the wild side I think
it's that's the end machine thing I
think it's ultimately going to be
different from this kind of
computational version com you know
computational complexity version of
these categories just because I think
that as we're discussing no matter what
there's going to be
those are going to have to be trackable
they're going to have to be
computationally reducible so they'll be
slightly different but it'll be
interesting to see
how we use both of them together to be
able to speak computationally to pockets
of reducibility and irreducibility where
when it's reducible you can use category
theory in order to have you know a kind
of strong Actuarial you know uh view of
what's Happening
I need to run I'm super late to
something else here but but um this is
great let us continue and
um you know seems like we have some
different directions Jonathan you do you
feel this is uh
you know we put a pause here yeah I mean
what I was kind of hoping to get out of
this meeting was more of a sense of I
mean
what I would like is to be able to have
a very concrete bridge that says you
know given that allows you to convert
very neatly between concrete categories
multi-way systems
um specifications of quantum circuits uh
you know possibly symbolic tensors Etc
um yes I think this was the introduction
to that discussion
right right because I think that's a
pretty complicated thing and I think I
think um uh
you know I think what we need to do next
time probably is to take all those
things you're mentioning and somebody
present
briefly about each of them
right and then let's see how similar or
not the formalisms actually are
okay because I think what you're doing
you were stating things here with
respect to the way that you construct
these categories and so on you're
stating these things very much as here
are the building blocks you know you're
basically giving these lists of
of how to build things up
and I don't know how similar that is
you know again these different things
that they're probably all fairly similar
but we need to you know next time let us
plan uh I don't even know who's uh I
guess Kristen is Project managing here
let's plan to get a you know and if we
can get a a precise analogy just an
example where we can look at it like
that that numerical multi-way system for
example if we can somewhat look at
something like that in all of these
different presentations
that would be helpful I know whether
that even makes sense for some of these
other things
but it's like what would how would you
think or pick something else or we can
have a a sort of a common thing to look
at maybe it's a more abstract version of
this with F's and G's
um
and what one just kind of practical
point so this was originally still is
this meeting was included as kind of a
design review I don't think I saw an
agenda until today so I was basically
prepared to like talk about colors and
fonts and stuff right because it's a
design review so whatever we plan for
next time can we get like an agenda just
so we can kind of prepare and well I
think Christian should try and pull that
together yes just so we can enter the
meeting with some you know some idea of
what we're actually going to discuss no
that that was that was my fault for not
preparing an agenda sooner that's um
it's not just you it's also this thing
was just called a design review which I
thought we're gonna like discuss angles
and Arrowhead sizes and you know you
know just like design details
right
um
all right we should wrap here uh good
stuff very nice to see all of this stuff
from Jonathan
um